two shootings to report this halloween
weekend both happening in the east
valley just hours apart one left a
person dead at a house party madison
kimbrough joins us live tonight with the
latest details madison
the first shooting took place here at
bella estate's apartment homes on twain
avenue around 10 40 last night
police have confirmed that the victim a
man was shot while in some type of
dispute with several others over a car
he was found dead on scene his identity
and age has not been released and
neither has any suspect information at
this time the second shooting happened
at a house party around 1 a.m on beasley
drive one woman was shot and two others
taken to the hospital for gunshot wounds
the woman who was shot died on scene
police say five men whose identities are
still unknown were not allowed inside
the house then sometime later the same
men drove by the house and started
shooting i saw everyone running out
after that you know we see the little
one of the girls that got hurt
or shot they were trying to give her cpr
and you know they were saying maybe she
would not make it the two other people
that were taken to the hospital were
transported with non-life-threatening
injuries
and if you have any information on any
of these shootings you are urged to
contract or contact metro immediately
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now